[Music]
you
all right so hello everyone very excited
to be here and I'd like to talk to all
of you about structure streaming and
Apache spark so quick intro on Who I am
I'm a software engineer at data bricks
work on the streaming team and our team
motto is we make your streams come true
I'm a spark committer and I'd like to
know you better as well so I'd like to
ask you a couple questions so who has
heard of Apache spark right now could
you raise your hand okay
great who is using spark for ETL no okay
great
who has heard of structured streaming
okay so 50% and who is using structure
streaming right now great thank you
awesome all right so I'd like to get all
of you to start using structure
streaming because it's super cool I'm
gonna show you why so about data breaks
we're the team that started the spark
project back in UC Berkeley now it's
Apache spark our mission is to make big
data simple and we have our unified
analytics platform as our product where
we where you can run manage spark
clusters on the cloud and run your codes
on notebook interfaces all right so
talking about streaming building robust
stream processing is hard that's like a
no-brainer there are a lot of
complexities involved one of them you
have complex data you have data stored
in many different silos and many
different data formats so you can have
your like some you know bucket
containing JSON files some bucket
containing CSV files you want to combine
all of those in addition data can be
dirty it'll generally be dirty and it
could be late it could be out of order
you have very complex workloads now with
big data we're trying to build these
very complex continuous pipelines where
we're combining streaming with
interactive queries where we want to
dashboards where we want to train our
machine learning models on like the
latest data and at the same time we're
dealing with very complex systems where
we have very diverse storage systems you
have databases you have Kafka you have
s3 or Kinesis some are eventually
consistent some provide ordered data
some provide data but no ordering
guarantees and you're working with
distributed system so you have to deal
with like system failures as well and
how to deal with these you know like
expected failures so with structure
streaming what we wanted to do was at
least simplify some of these problems
one of these is like first of all
structured streaming is built on top of
the spark sequel engine so you get the
fast scalable fault tolerant you know
spark workloads that you love and use
and it's built on top of the data frame
and data set API so it we have these
higher-level api's that you're used to
from pandas or from our where you're
using data frames and data sets where
you can deal with complex data and
complex workloads and you can do all
kinds of crazy transformations on your
data and what's the best part of SPARC
is that it has a very rich ecosystem of
data sources you can integrate with many
storage systems just out of the box
natively so with structure streaming
what we wanted to do was you should not
have to reason about streaming itself
you should just write your simple
queries and SPARC should continuously
update the results for you so what we're
dealing with is from this concept of
tables we're going to the concept of
unbounded tables infinite tables so
let's quickly take a high-level look
into a streaming query with a streaming
word count example so first of all your
stream has a source so the source you
specify one or more locations to read
from in this example we've specified
Kafka as a source we have built-in
support for files
on HDFS s3 and then you can read from
socket or you can plug in anything you
want you can plug in Cassandra using the
spark Cassandra connector and once you
have your sources you can include
multiple sources by Union in your data
frames then you do your transformations
this is your business logic so you used
to do this in batch so you just do your
group by and count and then catalyst
sparks equals underlying engine we'll
figure out how to execute these
transformations incrementally and then
the internal processing will be always
exactly once
so spark automatically streaming files
or queries when you write a data frame
or data set query using Scala Python and
Java are or even sequel what we do is we
get this logical plan this is your
intermediate representation then we
optimize it into a physical spark plan
which actually executes on the
underlying rdd's and what catalyst does
is it just incremental eise's these
physical plans over time so you get new
data in you get a new data out so once
you have your business logic you have to
output it to a sync you may have
multiple sources for your streaming
query but you can only have one sync you
can basically write it out to several
different sinks at the same time but
that'll mean you'll have different
queries so the sinks accept the output
of each batch or trigger
Instructor streaming and the when
supported sinks are transactional for
example the file sink by itself is
transactional you get exactly once
guarantees end to end and we have
another way to you can use a for each
writer where you can write your
arbitrary outputting logic you can write
your arbitrary sink to output data to
anywhere you want even like alerting
page or duty for example
then you have your output mode so what
our output modes this is basically
what's output to the sync at every
trigger so you can have a complete
output mode which outputs the whole
answer every time what does this mean
this means that if you were to not run a
streaming query but you had all of your
data in batch you wrote a batch job and
then you executed it you got the full
output once you stream you buy this and
you're in complete mode you're gonna get
the same output once you run through all
of your data update mode basically
outputs changed rows for like primary
keys this is generally done in
aggregations where you have some
grouping keys and then you're outputting
the updated partial results tier sync
every time and then the default is the
append mode where you're outputting new
rows only and the deal with append mode
is that in a pen mode you cannot rescind
your output so if you're doing like an
aggregation and you want to do it in a
pen mode what this means is that you can
now output the result unless you're sure
that it's never ever gonna change and
this generally means that you have some
like time-based data and you're dealing
with time and then you need to make sure
that okay now late data is not gonna
arrive so this result is final
so I'm outputting the final result the
trigger is when to output your data it
specified currently as a time it'll
eventually support data sizes so you can
buffer data up to some point and then
run a trigger if you don't specify a
trigger it means as fast as possible run
as fast as possible and we also have a
run once trigger which basically means
run my query for just one trigger and
stop it so here you can actually do the
scheduling yourself if you want to
leverage structured streaming but run
back jobs of ours for example if you're
not continuously getting data but you're
getting data once a day
well you know like once an hour then you
also have to specify a checkpoint
location which tracks the progress of
your streaming query and persistent
storage this is what provides us with
fault tolerance and it can be used to
restart the query if there are failures
beforehand with old spark streaming you
used to specify a checkpoint directory
but when you upgraded your spark version
it might not have worked well structure
streaming we fix that so you can upgrade
your spark versions and still get your
streaming working from where you left
off and then you call start to start
your streaming query so as I mentioned
we provide fault tolerance through our
check pointing our offsets of what's
process this save as JSON into a right
ahead log on your persistent storage and
you can resume after you change your
streaming transformations which proof
and this system provides us antenna
exactly once guarantees so let's talk
about a little bit more about complex
streaming ETL so traditional ETL what
you do is you have some data coming in
within seconds you're dumping it to
files and then since these files are
small you want to batch them up over
time so you wait hours and then you
write it out to some table and then your
data is available for your dashboards
and like ours and this is kind of a
problem when you want low latency it's
basically you have hours of delay before
taking a decision on your latest data
and if you want to do critical things
like intrusion detection or anomaly
detection this is just too late and it's
not acceptable
so with structure streaming you can
process your raw data as soon as it's
available and output it to your table
and it'll be ready for querying so let's
walk off an example so we're receiving
some JSON data and Apache Kafka we're
going to parse the nested JSON data that
we're receiving from cough
we're gonna flatten it and then we're
gonna store it in a parquet table we're
gonna get ed tend exactly once
guarantees and we're gonna get a very
nice
you know parquet table that can be
queried very quickly with spark so this
is basically all it takes you first
start off by specifying your kafka
source then the second block does your
transformation logic your value was a
the value you get off of Kafka was a
string you turn it into JSON you provide
the schema and then you basically the
UDF transforms your JSON data into
structured data and then you just write
it out and you can basically rewrite
remove all the vowels and you know put
parentheses or forward slashes and this
is basically what Python would look like
at the same time so reading from Kafka
how do you do it this is support
natively in SPARC you first provide your
list of brokers as a comma delimited
list then you provide us what to read
you providing like hey subscribe to
these comma separated list of topics or
subscribe to this pattern of topics or
you can use assign to read specific
partitions in your topics and then you
also can give us where to start from do
you want to start from the latest the
tip of the screen do you want to start
from what's earliest lee available in
Kafka or do you want to start from a
specific offsets and like this providing
specific offsets is generally very
helpful if you're like migrating your
workload to a different date a perform
at or a different location so the raw
data data set contains these columns you
have your key which is in binary you
have your values which is in binary
provided from Kafka you have your topics
you have your which partition it's
coming from you have the offsets and you
have the timestamps of when it was
ingested into Kafka
then you can turn your binary value to a
string let's call it JSON here and then
we used parse the JSON string using the
from JSON UDF and we're calling it data
and you can see how the JSON string
suddenly turns into the nested data
column type which contains our schema
then we flatten out the nested column
and then you have your fully full schema
out there so all of this we have
powerful built-in api's and UDF's to
perform very complex data
transformations moving from json to json
you can use explodes we have like
basically hundreds of functions and you
can check our blog post on some very
common data transformation applications
so once you've done your transformations
you want to write it out to some file
sync or another thing we like park' a
lot then spark sport spark a natively
basically what you might want to do is
partition it by date for example just so
that you can query basically providing
date when you have event time and your
data is like very useful so that you can
prune out like 90% of your data when
you're actually doing queries in the end
and park' since it's a columnar storage
you only read the columns that you're
interested in so you get super you know
high performance then you enable
checkpointing by providing the
checkpoint location option to provide
the place where you save the offset logs
and that start starts your streaming
query and basically what this does is
that it gives you a handle to your
streaming query and you can use this
handle to look for the recent progress
latest progress of your stream how many
records are processed how many how much
state is in your aggregation and you can
also use it to stop it or
throw an exception if the underlying
stream fails with a weight termination
and what this provides is in the end you
get data consistency on ad hoc queries
will structure streaming within seconds
and the thing here the most important
thing here which most other systems
don't have is that the park' table is
updated atomically and ensures prefix
integrity what this means is that if if
you were writing some files out then
your spark cluster diet or your node
died something died and then you have
some partial garbage left out written
out normally you know if you query that
data set you know you would see this
garbage data and it's not nice but with
structure streaming and the file sync
you either see all the updates or
nothing at all so partial results don't
show up and this is very helpful in
making sure you have a robust ETL
pipeline we have we love Kafka so we
have a lot of support that we added in
spark 2.2 or you can actually write out
to Kafka as well when you read from it
so you can do your aggregations and
write it out to other topics and your
data frame must have a value field it
could be string it could be binary that
if you don't provide a key field will
use a null so that it'll be randomly
partitioned and what you can also do is
you can also run batch queries on Kafka
as well which makes coffee a very
powerful storage platform so notice how
here we're not actually calling read
stream we're actually calling read and
this will make the data in Kafka
available as a batch data frame and you
can use this just to make sure that if
you have any problems with your data
this just makes it super easy to debug
what's going on
with your data and we have support for
Kinesis and data break front time in our
data breaks platform basically similarly
provide a region
of where your Kinesis stream is you
provide a comma-separated list of stream
names and then you also provide an
initial position and it gives you a very
similar schema to your Kafka schema and
then you can do whatever you want with
it so if you're dealing with streaming
you want to work with generally work
with time so event time support was one
of the biggest things lacking in old
spark streaming with these streams you
might
what people want to do now is you want
to you you might want to aggregate
statistics by event time and you want to
handle the cases where event events can
arrive late or out of order so windowing
for example on event time is just
another type of grouping instructor
streaming it's basically another UDF
here we have our timestamp column we're
grouping it in two windows of one hour
this is a tumbling window so windows of
one hour one hour one hour if you have
one more parameter you'd make it a
sliding window and then if you add one
more parameter you can provide a start
offset so if you want to create windows
of hours but you know start it off at 15
minutes past the hour if you want to do
something more interesting if you want
to group by your device for example but
that's generating your IOT data you just
add that to your group by statement and
then you have your aggregation and then
you can calculate your average signal
and we do support you that you daffs so
either the fine aggregate functions you
can write arbitrary logic to do all
these crazy things so stateful
processing in a distributed system is
pretty hard and the way we provide fault
tolerance in these cases is through
storing a distributed state in between
triggers so each trigger you read your
previous state you combine it with your
state for that trigger and then you
write your updated state at the end of
the trigger and this way if you if you
stop your stream and restart you can
pick off from your left off state the
state is generally stored in memory but
it's written backed by a right ahead log
that's writing to HDFS or s3 and this
provides fault tolerant exactly once
guarantees and structure streaming
automatically handles late-late data and
what we do is we keep old stayed around
for old windows of data for example just
to be able to handle these late data but
you notice I mean if you're gonna keep
late old stayed around then this state
could grow indefinitely boundedly and
you know when's it gonna stop
so how is it gonna scale you have that
problem so we solve that problem through
water marking where the water mark is
basically a moving threshold of how late
data is you know like how late data can
be giving your expectations and when you
can actually drop old state and say ok
this results never gonna change from now
on it trails behind the max scene event
time and the trailing gap is
configurable it's totally up to you it
totally depends on your system and you
know data producers and how it works is
as follows so data newer than the
watermark may be late but we allow it to
aggregate data older than the watermark
is too late and it's dropped so because
we're dropping all those late records
that key is never gonna be updated again
so we can actually automatically also
delete the state for that key to limit
the number of intermediate state kept in
memory the watermark is used useful only
in stateful aggregations and stateful
operations such as aggregations
calling distinct or like dropping
duplicates and some advanced operations
like map groups with state it is ignored
in non stateful streaming queries and
batch queries but if you do provide your
watermark we still track the statistics
so you can also in your ETL pipeline see
how you know the statistics of your
event time while your append-only ETL
job is running and you provide it with
the with watermark API we provided your
event time column and then you provide a
delay key for example here ten minutes
so walking off an example you can see we
have three records coming in in this
trigger the x-axis is the processing
time the y-axis is the event time and
what we said is we've used the watermark
of 10 minutes so also notice that how
you know the event time 12:14 around
arrived at like 1212
you could have clock skew we could have
things coming from the future so that's
something you need to take into
consideration when you're setting the
watermark so the system tracks the max
observed event time and based on that
max event time we subtract the delay key
and we set a watermark then once we
receive new records we still increase
the max by the yellow line the red
records arrived late but we still
consider them in our aggregation and the
record below is basically too late and
it's ignored in our processing and it's
the state has dropped you can read more
about it in this blog post once the
slides are out so what this provides is
a very clean separation of concerns
where you're separating the query
semantics from the processing details or
business logic so we have several time
related things here your query semantics
is how do i group my data by time
you use that in your window function for
example this is used both in batch and
streaming and we've set five minutes
here the processing details how late can
my data be you provide that with your
with watermark function and then how
often do I want to emit results that's
your trigger so you specify that here
for example with 10 seconds let's park
2.2 we support arbitrary stateful
operations the method for this is called
map groups with state it applies any
user-defined stateful function to a
user-defined state basically you give us
a grouping key we provide you all the
values receipt for that grouping key and
we provide you a state that you can
update or use during your function and
what you output from this function is
what's emitted to the sink or downstream
it's supported in Scala and Java and it
supports perky timeouts both in event
time or processing time other
interesting operations that you might
want to do is for example deduplication
so you use that with drop duplicates and
watermark the watermark allows you to
basically limit the state the first time
you receive a result for this key you
will output the result every time you
get it again you'll just ignore it and
once the watermark passes we'll just
drop it from the state and then if we
receive the same record again we just
drop it from the input as well you can
do stream back joins of course from
streaming data frames to batch data
frames using the join function and it
could also do stream team joins you can
use map groups with state or flat
mappers with state to write your
arbitrary joining logic but direct
support using the join function is
coming with SPARC 2.3 in fact we have
just merged inner eques joins with time
ranges in SPARC it's available and
master
so since this is a data engineering
conference I just want to talk about a
little bit about the ETL that we do at
data brakes since I think it's gonna be
very relevant to all of you so I'd like
to first explain you the evolution of
our data pipeline this is nothing
special this is basically what everyone
builds but I just like you to tell my
story of how we built it at data brakes
while I was on the data engineering team
so we had events going into kafka in our
case we also used Kinesis and what we
wanted in the end was to have some
streaming analytics to do some alerting
and you know monitoring and we also want
to track you know the historical views
of you know like how our customers are
using our platform or how our services
are behaving over time so we use shorter
streaming apache spark to run our
streaming analytics this is great but
kafka only stores your data for one day
or seven day or how long you configure
it so you can't query historical results
so how do you get historical queries
well it's the same data frame API so
it's kind of simple I guess you can use
the lambda architecture you know
everyday you can run a batch job that
just dumps all the data into s3 or into
your data Lake any okay you got your
lambda architecture set but what do you
want to do next
from this data Lake you can power your
reporting which is great but now the
challenge number two is messy data so
you have dirty data coming in okay we're
gonna use spark to validate our results
I mean we have to do it on both the
streaming side and both a batch side
it's kind of you know like there's some
work put into it but let's say me yeah
is okay it's kind of easy so we do it
but then once you do the validation it's
kind of too late you've already written
out your data to your data lake so you
want to fix your mistakes and failures
so how do you do that so okay you know
like let's say I run my batch job once a
day so I partition my data by date so
every day I can actually overwrite
whatever is in my data lake so if there
are any mistakes or if there are any
failures I can just overwrite all the
data and like failures are like you know
your ec2 instance getting spot killed so
you wrote out some partial files you
need to clean all that stuff up with
your batch stuff and you need to do all
this reprocessing on your data Lake so
okay we have step three and then you
know like our data scientists come and
say this
you know like data Lake querying this
table sucks it's just too slow and then
you'll look into why that is and then
you see oh there are like so many small
files that I was reading from the stream
so you know if you want to make the
latest data available you have to put
out small files then you're gonna do you
know like you're gonna compact these
small files into large you know one
gigabyte park' files which will give you
the optimal performance so you're gonna
run a compaction job but oh no what
happens you know while I was doing the
compaction job you know my reporting
jobs failed because the file not found
exception because I just deleted the
files while the other job was using them
crap so okay we have to schedule these
you know like the compaction jobs at
2:00 a.m. at night since while no one's
looking at you know the reports so what
I want to introduce is a solution to all
of this with data breaks Delta basically
we wanted to solve all these problems
make it super simple and we believe
we've built the first unified data
management system that delivers the
scale of a data Lake
the reliability and performance of a
data warehouse and the low latency of
streaming and how do we do that
so data breaks Delta provides you the
good of Delta lakes by providing massive
scale on Amazon s3 it uses open formats
like Parque ro RC so you're not locked
in you can always move your data out and
use it with another system and it allows
you know advanced applications like
running machine learning or real time
applications and provides you the good
of data warehouses where you have
pristine high quality data you have
transactional reliability and you get
fast queries of 10 to 100 X which you'd
normally don't get on data Lakes so this
enables a whole new set of app complex
applications so how does it work under
the hood it provides the massive scale
by decoupling compute and storage so you
can use as much compute as you want the
storage s3 it's managed you don't care
about it it provides reliability through
asset transactions and data validation
so this is one of the biggest problems
when working with data leaks that you
don't get these asset transactions you
get high performance through data
indexing and caching where we've
observed you know running queries on
like petabyte scale data to run a
hundred x faster and you also enable
real-time streaming ingest and provide
low latency to downstream applications
so you take this canonical built data
pipeline and what you transform it into
is the Delta architecture basically
reading from Kafka or data Lake using
structured streaming writing out to data
bricks Delta and once you write it out
to data bricks Delta you can still use
streaming or batch jobs to run your
streaming analytics and your reports
and you get all of this with the best of
the data lakes a scale of data lakes you
get the reliability through transactions
you get performance through caching and
indexing and you get low latency what
structure streaming we use Delta data
breaks heavily we process about fourteen
more than fourteen billion records and
at an hour with like ten nodes and we
meet diverse latency requirements as
efficiently as possible when it ranges
from seconds to minutes and kind of the
architecture that we have is basically
as follows what we have is we first read
our data we write you know like raw
tables which you know like we don't do a
lot of processing on them we do the data
cleaning that we want we put it in the
format that we want and then we write it
out first and then we split it up into
many summary tables where these summary
tables are also updated by streaming
jobs and you get compaction and all that
stuff so that you can query these
summary tables which are pretty small
very efficiently and these summary
tables are actually what power our
analytics or reporting tools and the
thing here is basically raw tables are
huge in size we have tables over like
hundreds of terabytes the summary tables
are tens of gigabytes are a hundred
hundreds of gigabytes and what we do is
we also the raw tables you know their
value decreases over time so we drop you
know data that's older than seven days
for example you know Kafka keeps things
inside for one day or Kinesis keeps it
in one day the raw tables keep it in for
seven days so if you messed up something
you can always go back and do your
backfill for like the full seven days of
data and the basically the whole
retention is totally up to you you draw
up when you want to and then summary
tables we keep them all out around for
longer because they're very useful
they're small and we don't need to you
know
throw them away as much because they're
pretty valuable so for more info on all
of this we you can check out the
structure streaming programming guide on
the Apache web site you can read we have
a huge list of data breaks blog posts
for more focused discussions we have an
anthology of technical assets on
structure streaming which contains tens
of blog posts on advanced usage of
structure streaming and follow our blog
post so to see more and more information
on structure streaming and try out
Apache spark and data bricks unified
analytics platform that provides
notebooks to create a collaborative
workspace we have a free version the
Community Edition which you can try out
today and data bricks runtime three
point four is coming out data bricks
runtime is an optimized version of
Apache spark optimized for the cloud has
many caching and optimization layers
then provides enterprise security tools
and we are hiring of course very high
growth I'm also on the careers page
which is kind of flattering so check us
out so if you want to work on all these
cool tools and technologies so thank you
and I can take questions if we have time
and I love Henry Kissinger's comment of
does anyone have any questions for my
answers happy to take them
[Applause]
hey when can we expect integration of
the structured streaming with the Apache
beam Apache beam that I mean it's I
would think it was supported I'm not
exactly sure I'm not active in Apache
beam depends on the open source
community I would say or Google so yeah
any other questions
yeah this is another question about
Apache beam but I want to put the onus
on you to
I mean beam is doing a lot of work on
establishing the semantics so streaming
queries like they've defined watermark
kind of differently than you've defined
it blink hair streaming sequel what
efforts are you making to try and
harmonize what you're producing with
what other people are producing because
the last thing do you know the community
wants is divergent implementations of
sequel and you you claim you're making
it simple but the semantics of sequel
and especially streaming sequel is
incredibly complex so the kind of the
details of this stuff really matters
great question
so on that point well Apache beam is
providing a higher level API over you
know spark flank and data flow and what
it it's trying to provide as this API
that combines all of these together so
if these systems work differently and
have different api's I mean it's it's
pretty much a wrapper around all that's
there defining the semantics as well
mmm-hmm I see I mean we can talk about
this more offline I don't have too much
context on the semantics of being
[Music]